good morning it's Chantal here and of
course Pedro is not in bed with me this
morning he's at the computer say hi to
the camera
hi hi I'm Pedro from the mikado poverty
this is my beautiful wife can tell from
your eyes tell your yeah we've been in
quarantine for about a month now this is
how I'm going to get ready to go to my
living room slash kitchen slash office
slash gaming room Pedro and I are
spending a lot more quality time
together
Pedro bambe that babe I wonder if he can
hear me or pace just ignores me
sometimes I guess always Mar 14 2014 I
and then and brings groceries back to
the apartment but I don't leave at all I
have the first and you sauce there I am
risk my life every time I go shopping so
how do you feel staying home during
quarantine do you like it
I can play more video games it can be
with pinky here you are good because
your life is the computer but I live in
the world
I'll even they were too wasn't me pinky
I'm really tired of being in the house
it's just like so claustrophobic to me
so we have the kitchen and we have this
and then the coffee table because your
mom has a kitchen and a dining room and
a living room and three bedroom is like
10% the price that we pay here I love my
husband but I do wish that I have my own
space
he has his gaming station and we never
anticipated me having to move all of my
studies from the school library into the
the princess the Queen the pinky Winky
dinky Winky dinky Winky
[Music]
[Music]